are you ready yet so you'll have Prince
Albert in icon are you ready Ethan
right yes okay okay you know what
this physical challenge was so weird and
difficult we're just gonna give the
points to both of you it's above you yes
yes my god Banco general
my god
I'm gonna starve arthritic and I don't
know where I am right now I'm the
Nostalgia Critic and ever since I was a
child I always want to play games
quoting movies and TV with my friends
the only problem was I had no friends
well now that I have power I can take my
friends by force with the help of my new
pal general anaesthetic
I can kidnap all the friends I want and
force them to answer questions am i
Saved by the Bell style scent there will
be last trivia those disturbing cartoons
that give you night terrors but most of
all there will be fun the laughter and
joy will last however long I want heads
up America or this is pop quiz hotshot
[Music]
probably gonna regret this but I'm begum
general anesthetic I'm back hahahahaha
so I'm not gonna lie you were a very
unique duo to kidnap here and I'd like
to say I'm interested to find out more
about you but I'll probably just become
more afraid but uh I got a bar special
little snowflake oh ho oh she got half
of that right and we're gonna find out
more about you right now
it says here Edie you have two other
friends named Ed tell me about them
oh yeah there is double D he is very
smart he wears a stuck on his head
hahaha and then berries he is very short
and very loud and very lovable haha we'd
like to make scams together and make
money for joggers hahahaha you're very
strange person I'm not gonna talk to you
Ethan
oh it says here that you actually dream
of one day being the host of a game show
oh man love game shows big fan in fact I
love them so much I wanna be a game
shows game show host so much I would
kill for it
this is gonna be a fun episode let's
find out how to play it each contestant
is asked a series of questions involving
the sounds of quotes
if the contestant does not know the
answer but can make the nostalgia critic
laugh ten points are still given but
look out for the spazzy the first one to
hit their buzzer when they appear ends
the round well the other has to pay the
penalty through round two where the
quotes get even harder the winner with
the most points face off against the
nostalgia critic and a one-on-one match
if the contestant wins they walk out
with a cash prize and also their lives
if they lose the cash prize will be
added to the next contestants winning
all righty are you both ready hello
button I'll take that as a yes don't hit
it I get notes it don't give him points
don't stop it then gone finish this line
from on the waterfront I could have been
a second close contender Ethan in Jerry
Maguire named one of two actors who said
show me the money Tom Cruise yes it
which sci-fi character originally wanted
to go to the tashi station to pick up
some power converters Oh Luke Skywalker
yes
you're not as why don't you look Ethan
the stranger says this story takes place
in the early 90s near our war with what
people the sandpeople you're kind of
right the Iraqi which Watchmen
characters last words were it's a joke
it's all a joke mother forgive me the
comedian yes Ethan which movie had Jim
Carrey scream that goddamn pen is blue
liar liar
yes I also would have accepted man on
the moon because you could just see that
as a bit just out of nowhere you
wouldn't the movie for that Edie
which character in Jurassic Park said
dinosaurs eat man woman inherits the
earth the girl character I think she
mumbled a lot
yeah given the points for that I assume
you're talking about Jeff Goldblum even
in spider-man which characters said I
trust my barber statefarm gaje I can't
think of his name no that made me laugh
I'll give you that the State Farm guy
are you one spider-man laughing from you
it's finish this line from in the heat
of the night they call me the star tubs
and really IDI watch in the heat of the
night
oh it was for a film studies class I
like watching movies haha I'm tempted to
take that point away from you even in
ants with a Z name the actor who said
you know my mother never had time for me
when you're the middle child in a family
of five million you don't get any
attention who watch ants i watch i watch
oh yeah fun to crawl around there's the
red ones and the black ones and a few
paths finish this line from The Goonies
Goonies never say die maybe later yes
Ethan what movie had the line beneath
this mask there is an idea mr. Creedy
and ideas are full across no V for
Vendetta
Batman poke a little lighter in a little
heavier Oh
which actor in hook said to live would
be an awfully big adventure Robin
Williams yes something you will not know
in the near future when you win this or
not
Ethan which action movie actors said
come out to the coast we'll get together
have a few laughs yes yes yes I got it
sure thank dog keep dog he you are done
you are done whether you get more points
in this or not I don't like that you're
in the lead he wants to take away
another toe Ethan
sad to say you do not get penalized but
and here does which is great joy to me
it is a penalty of my choosing and you
know what he inspired me and I just got
to know what the hell is would sound and
look like as Batman oh I'm gonna regret
this while we get him in the outfit
Ethan you get to watch the spicy cartoon
thank you for watching me across the
street every second eat it
honey honey all right we have a punk is
nothing but top of the crowd right so
maybe this was a mistake
this was such a huge mistake let's just
start round two big dog Ethan please
pull it together by God
Edie what movie had the line that's what
I love about highschool girls I get
older they stay the same age why would
it's good guess no Dazed and Confused
which I think the actors often were
during that Ethan what India Jones
character said you call this archeology
I can't do this as name mr. Jones you
know damn it that made me laugh so I had
to give it to you know accentuate Henry
Jones senior bat Edie you should be good
at this one which two actors from the
1989 Batman said you are my number one
guy like Nicholson and Bob know Bob had
like two lines and the whole thing they
weren't that long Jack Palance it looked
like Waldo's about to rob a bank
what early 90s movie has the line get
off my train Thomas the Tank Engine the
revengeance the revengeance I'm using
that word of the future that reason you
message the wrong train they're already
scary enough they don't need any more
help from you and which rocky villain
said prediction pain Club are lying yes
that ed knows his Rocky movies I love
mr. P ha ha ha
he doesn't love you Ethan finish this
ghostbusters line we Came we saw we
destroyed the shell of it it's
practically the same thing
kicked its ass so close your time don't
lose it don't let him win
there was a pause for that then I was
right yeah I can't guess it wasn't funny
enough just you need to either be
funnier or no pumpkin eat our head which
sci-fi villain said time is the fire in
which we burn only the claw knows no
that's wrong keep it please please keep
us right get this right which Nicolas
Cage movie head Nick scream I lost my
hand
I lost my bride all of them struck I
didn't laugh I didn't laugh hey Nicolas
Cage's funny okay dude number Brad again
better and in Full Metal Jacket are lee
ermey said if you survive recruit
training you will be a weapon you will
be a minister of death praying for war
true or false true in Star Wars attack
the clones which characters said I don't
like second it's such a funny line it's
hard to even get it all out I don't like
Sam it's coarse and irritating and it
gets everywhere
Anakin yes one of the great memorable
Star Wars lies in Mary Poppins when Burt
said stop that I can never stop Mike
like what job does can you just shoot
him in the leg don't worry what I see on
their way it's it's I'm liking you again
I'm like Ed in Mary Poppins when Burt
says I know a man with a wooden leg
named Smith what is uncle Albert's reply
oh we must go to the same hardware store
not even close
that is what's the name of his other lay
come on classic classic joke hi finish
this line from the movie dune Oh God
beer is the while I'm feeling right now
in my pants yeah okay yeah I'm only
laughing cuz I made my brother laughing
he's the dude fan so so I know I'm not
to actually be funny one of these days
I'll get me the first ten minutes F in
what movie did David Krumholtz say the
shit has hit the fan in who's David
comma holes good guess it's actually 10
Things I Hate About You which I can list
very easily in which Star Trek movie can
you find the line you have been
experienced Shakespeare until you've
heard it in the original Klingon Star
Trek 3 no Star Trek 6 the undiscovered
country but it doesn't matter because I
mean the level is over
[Applause]
and it brings me so little joy in saying
this but sadly the time has come for you
to go away far away from me with a gun
in you anywhere I don't care okay can I
ask me a letter guys welcome to my place
what can I do graduate please can't do
it no no no we have to give general
anaesthetic I think you've been waiting
it for a while to do it general that
it's wonderful I am so happy
Ethan I hope you make it to the end but
I don't care cuz it just no he's not if
you would like to be a contestant a pop
quiz hotshot and live in the Chicagoland
area
send a video via YouTube stating your
name 8 and why you the figure with the
other contestant
welcome back to pop quiz hotshot Eastern
congratulations you'll be battling
against the critic in our final round
I'll be reading seven questions whoever
answers the most correctly will win this
a new boat load of boat choice courtesy
of Bo Toys R Us also $100 in cash and of
course your life brilliant
alright I'm going to be reading each of
you Quentin Tarantino quotes you can
have to match the quote with the movie
are you ready yes are you ready Kemosabe
yes excellent here we go Ethan I don't
tip because society says I have to pulp
fiction incorrect critic Sicilians are
great liars the best in the world I'm
Sicilian incorrect Ethan wait no country
I ever heard of they speak English at
what pulp fiction correct critic okay
Ted to pay attention here I'm going to
make two piles on the bar one pile which
is yours the other pile which could be
yours so far incorrect
Ethan now do we all agree that what we
are dealing with is vampires
critic
I'll bet besides maybe an afro you'll
look exactly how you did it 29 Kill Bill
Vol 1
incorrect Ethan when you grow up if you
still feel raw about it I'll be waiting
Kill Bill Vol 1 correct critic and what
pray tell is d 5 point Palme exploding
heart technique Cuban avoiding to
correct Ethan well sub man Mike I'm
butterfly my friend Jungle Julia over
here says that jukebox inside is pretty
impressive incorrect critic we've got a
German here who wast died for his
country oblige here even or a spastic
correct ethan kill why people get paid
for it what's not to like Django
Unchained correct critic I do believe
Marcellus Wallace my husband your boss
told you to take me out to do whatever I
want it all fiction
correct Ethan it's amusing to me to
torture a cop correct
and finally critic if on your journey
you should encounter God God will be cut
Kill Bill volume 1 correct and the
winner is a tie god damn it's alright
well critic Ethan it's time for
rock-paper-scissors wait well really
don't one two three go
okay Ethan you win my friend all 42 whoo
but nevertheless I'm glad you get to
wear it and you get to walk out of here
with your life so sir congratulations I
hate you get out of here I never want to
see we will see you next time on rock
paper scissors really really yeah why
did I come up with that I think Brad did
oh yeah yeah boy this was a special
episode was quite when I think of it
where it's special I think of this
episode definitely very much you know
but I have to admit it still wasn't as
strange as that shader guy yeah the kind
of treatment stuff like that shot at war
I remember we did like the plug at the
end if I go to my web sites that me
imagine that Ed guy had a website or
even a Facebook and they want to be like
you know Facebook my name is Ed or
something like that so we're the post a
link at the bottom maybe we want to do
him any favors oh thank you oh thank god
he's not here to do that indeed yeah no
no yeah this you made sure he's dead
right absolutely
[Music]